malgré les nombreux appels au calme qui
ont précédé le ton monte très vite la
situation est à deux doigts de dégénérer
on a qu'a fait la nation a montré tous
les partis l'après-midi évolution à la
romieu à la mairie à trois mois ils
n'ont pas dit non
le maire ne veut pas se mélanger au
pouvoir un peu les gens mais au delà de
la question du titre de propriété que
chaque partie semble revendiquer
nous sommes face à un cas typique d'un
division louis marie sainte et du
municipal de l'opposition à ducos
seuls présents à ce rassemblement n'a
pas manqué de le souligner la division
la division sûrement soit il ya
quelqu'un de propriété et la benjamine
discute pas mais à mon avis on est dans
un cadre des divisions et ses seins tout
symbolique parce que je crois que le
monsieur qui a vécu plus de 120 ans une
fille je fini par retrouver la trace de
la fameuse fille en question
celle ci aussi a déjà saisi la justice
pour faire valoir ses droits de
succession ce contentieux n'est pas le
seul du genre en martinique il est un
exemple concret des problèmes liés à
l'indivision
au risque parfois de déboucher sur des
situations dramatiques et sollicité le
maire de la commune n'a pas souhaité
s'exprimer si vous écoutez la première
il est 7e 11 le rire le merveilleux cela
peut être une thérapie et des enfants
malades à la mfr ont une belle surprise
hier ils ont eu droit à un spectacle de
magie il était dispensée par
l'association mission magie qui vient de
l'hexagone et qui travaillent souvent
dans les établissements de santé
reportage de fabrice théodose
[Musique]
de la magie dans les yeux de ses enfants
avec ses tours mise en place par la
mission magie en martinique les missions
humanitaires et bénévole dans les écoles
mais aussi les hôpitaux comme la mfm e
elodie charles et instigatrice de cette
mission magie c'est vraiment rapporté
un moment de vie et de joie pour les
enfants leur permettre en fait de
retrouver joie de vivre
émerveillement et force pour continuer
le combat contre la maladie
à mon sens des actions telles que celles
ci ont vraiment toute leur place dans le
processus de guérison
puisque quand on quand on quand on
intervient comme ça avec eux eh ben
c'est une grande parenthèse grande
parenthèse où on ne parle plus la
maladie mais on parle de la vie fait
avec messages y est cadre de santé à la
messe mais elle va dans le même sens
surtout pour les enfants qui en ont
vraiment besoin d'oublier la douleur
j'ai envie de dire leur douleur leur mot
max90 émaux ts donc ça leur permet de
s'exprimer puis ça leur permet
effectivement comme je vous dis
d'oublier un petit peu qu'ils sont
malades qui sont à l'hôpital
les enseignants également son félicite
comme patricia barrès professeur des
écoles spécialisé ça leur permet de
s'évader d'oublier un peu la maladie de
voir autre chose si tu a ainsi atteint
qui sortent pas du tout y'en a même qui
soit de l'étranger et qui passait des
mois le but aller qui ne voient pas les
clés de la matinée qui ne connaissent
que l'hôpital donc pour moi c'est un pis
et le magicien marciel sorriaux de
l'association magis les enfants malades
ce qu'ils veulent c'est qu'on leur sorte
qu'on les sorte du contexte qu'ils
oublient un petit peu l'hôpital et
qu'ils oublient un petit peu tout ça et
la magie est un super vecteur pour ça on
arrive à vraiment les faire décrocher et
à les emmener ailleurs le temps une
heure de spectacle et nous si notre
objectif lors du bonheur pour qu'ils
oublient un peu tout ça voilà pendant
quinze jours ses tours de magie sera
donc donnée un peu partout sur 10
[Musique]
et
le rire et l'amusement maintenant pour
les plus grands et oui nous poursuivons
notre découverte des chansons du
carnaval 2010 8 aujourd'hui plein feux
sur les eyzies pote une bande de copains
en fait ils sont deux ils s'inspirent
des douze salopards et veulent garder
l'anonymat
les hypothèses existent depuis 2013 et
cette année encore ils ne sont pas
avares de production déjà deux titres
que l'on entend sur les radios il s'agit
de elle tourne et 2 à 0 007
entrées/sorties chanté par joël sans
complexe assez bien son nom à la
librairie a rencontré le leader du
groupe cesi potes de deux personnes
c'est qu'on va dire que c'est des daft
punk hall low cost on ne connaît pas
assez d'armes sans argent ceux qui nous
connaissent savent combien portent des
casques et puis surtout on est aussi des
producteurs
c'est pour ça qu'on ne sera pas votre
nom c'est pour ça qu'on est quand même
un bon commercial et il ya un truc qui
nous manquait c'était vraiment les
paroliers
donc on a on a récupéré joël on a vu en
prestations et tout ça elle écrit
énormément donc on a voulu revenir pour
qu'un navale traditionnelle mais avec
notre patois
elle s'est inspirée de ce qui se passe à
sainte-marie et puis nous on a mis un
ami en musique on a fait les choeurs en
fait on a rajouté une couche derrière
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui nous inspire c'est oui
c'est l'humour et puis c'est surtout on
se met à la place des gens nous c'est
notre secret à dire que quand on fait un
titre quand on fait on va dire un tempo
il ce genre de choses là on s'imagine
toujours en boîte de nuit et ce genre de
choses nous on s'amuse on fait attention
babel tourne pas tu sais nous on
s'inspire énormément de la houle donc on
a repris un petit peu les ritournelles
de la rue et vie bon un petit peu
titillé genre de choses il ya quand même
un petit message sur elle tourner parce
qu'avec tout ce qu'on voit sur les
réseaux sociaux à ressasser tout ça on
se moque de ce genre de choses là pour
que justement des filles
même les garçons qui vont se faire
filmer dans des situations un peu
bizarre se pose quand même la question
alain ivory les secteurs ya plus de 16
minutes on n'est pas en retard on fait
vite c'est la fin de cette édition merci
de l'avoir suivi je vous retrouve à huit
et on revient rapidement sur une des
infos à porter de ce journal club du hac
l'inquiétude concernant laetitia pélage
la jeune femme de 25 ans a disparu
depuis vendredi les gendarmes et sa
famille la recherche
une information que vous pouvez
retrouver sur notre site la première
point fr merci claude gratien quelques
semaines avant la célébration de
l'abolition de l'esclavagé en mai
prochain il est important de rappeler la
nécessité d'explorer notre histoire dans
toutes ses dimensions au nom du devoir
de mémoire
si la réflexion proposée ce matin par
jean-marc parti qui ne sait que les
esclaves ont joué un rôle déterminant
dans leur libération en 1848 qui n'a
compris que les travaillons c'est en
ville ont été les premiers acteurs en
première ligne des dernières
escarmouches ayant mené le gouverneur
rostollan a proclamé l'abolition d'un
esclavage
question naïve qui se pose est pourtant
du temps de nos parents et grands
parents à l'école nul ne leur enseigne
est que la lutte des captifs contre leur
servitude a été continu dès les premiers
temps de la colonisation
aucune mention dans les manuels
scolaires de rahan traces dans le récit
de notre histoire transmis de génération
en génération
ce n'est que très récemment que des
intellectuels ont mis en exergue le rôle
de la masse des esclaves dans leurs mets
et émancipation historien allemand
nicolas a été le pionnier des études
consacrées à la révolution anti
esclavagiste et cela dans les années
grosso modo il y adopte un demi siècle
que la connaissance sur la fin de la
période esclavagiste se diffuse dans le
camp social lentement mais sûrement
loppement car jusqu'à présent nous
sommes encore nombreux à ignorer
l'essentiel sur cette période
sûrement car les jeunes d'aujourd'hui
dispose heureusement d'une masse de
documents pour savoir et se fait en
leurs opinions à ce propos cependant il
reste encore beaucoup à apprendre et
beaucoup à découvrir sur notre histoire
ancienne sur ces héros et héroïnes c'est
mentir et ses grandes personnalités
par exemple sur ces hommes de couleur
libre autrement appelée mulâtre sans eux
le combat pour l'abolition n'aurait pas
eu le même écho à l'extérieur à paris
notamment dans la colonie non plus dans
leur concurrence avec les plantes et un
becquet a été féroce dans les
années précédant l'émancipation gageons
que le 170e anniversaire de l'abolition
de l'esclavagé puisse nous donner
l'occasion d'explorer davantage notre
histoire
histoire de mieux affronter l'avenir
[Musique]
si vous êtes étudiants en colocation
devez vous quand même payer l'assurance
habitation pedro monnerville répondra à
cette question dans quelques secondes ce
sera juste après ça ou caddie avec alain
ivory qui reçoit aujourd'hui
huguette bourgeois présidente du
tribunal des prud'hommes
[Musique]
joue et gagne sa place pour le concert
du 27 janvier de maddie musique au top
en écoutant djiby entre 6h et 9h sur la
première à tout moment tu peux être tiré
au sort envoie tout de suite par sms
musique
m yz ica au 97000 service édité par
access interactive 65 centimes d'euro +
coût du sms
made in music en concert avec la
première
[Musique]
invité de sa coalition matar guèye
bourgeois la toute nouvelle présidence
du conseil des prud'hommes cet organisme
paritaire administrés par des employeurs
et des salariés et vous êtes du collège
et salariés précisément du syndicat cdmt
huguette bourgeois bonjour bonjour votre
mandature qui se poursuivra il me semble
jusqu'en 2021 si cela va se dérouler
sous le signe de la réforme entre autres
voilà il ya la réforme qui qui va tout
bouleverser
et ça a déjà commencé avec le fait que
les les conseillers n'ont pas été aidés
méprisant précédemment mais désigné le
mode de saisine a changé alors ça veut
dire quoi exactement contre 1 auparavant
les les justiciables il remplissait
juste un feuillet recto verso
maintenant c'est beaucoup plus détaillé
il y a beaucoup plus d'explications à
fournir à la justice pour pour est-ce
qu'il faut se faire accompagner qu'on va
aux prud'hommes
est-ce qu'il faut bien avoir un avocat
ou pas ou bien se dire qu'on va on a la
possibilité de faire appel à un avocat
on a également la possibilité de faire
appel à un défenseur syndical
c'est mieux que de se dire qu'on ira
qu'on y va tout seul si on maîtrise son
dossier
c'est très bien sinon il est préférable
vraiment parce que on rentre en plein
dans dans le droit du travail et on ne
maîtrise pas forcément le droit du
travail
le défenseur syndical et l'avocat oui
généralement oui alors il y a aussi dit
l'iphone macron le plafonnement des
indemnités des salariés qui font appel
aux prud'hommes qu'est-ce que ça va
changer quoi concrètement cet aspect des
choses
si je ne je ne crois pas que ça va
changer vraiment combat dans le
fonctionnement voyait pour le salarié ça
va changer quoi ça veut dire que vous
pourriez plus données fixée d d d d d d
comment dire des indemnités supérieures
à ce qu'elles tiff qui fixée par la loi
ne nous allons respecter la loi nous
avons l'obligation d'appliquer la loi
maintenant nous ferons le salarié il
sera rempli de son empire trip qui sera
dédommagée de son entier préjudice en
fonction de ses demandes
les demandes sont et sont examinés au
cas par cas
chaque demande donc le salarié qui
demande
je ne sais pas il a 15 ans de boîte ils
demandent une somme qu'il aura fixé
nous allons nous baser sur le décret
pour pouvoir appliquer la porte mais ce
qu'il ya toujours est ce que vous pouvez
aller au delà de ceux qui n'ont même pas
discrétionnaire du juge le nom s'annonce
assez unique on nous appliquerons la
loire c'est notre rôle d'ailleurs
d'accord autres autre aspect c'est la
rupture conventionnelle collective
quelle vision vous avez vous de cette de
cette mesure la gérer alors non on n'est
pas là pour commenter bien sûr les les
orientations politiques
mais ce que ça ce n'est pas une mesure
qui risque de douche pas de mettre en
danger même le le rôle des prud'hommes
nom lors le prie de me jouer un rôle de
régulation
nous saurons nous serons avec équité et
donc je ne pense pas que ça va quoi
quand où qu'on pense généralement tout
avec les nouvelles lois macron temps
tout sera
négocier quand tout est négocié avant
coûts totaux négocié dans l'entreprise
est ce qu'on a toujours besoin des
prud'hommes à ce moment là il y aura
toujours des litiges entre entre les
deux parties il faudra il y aura
toujours des litiges et c'est là que
nous interviendrons peut-être que nous
aurons à l'avenir moins de dossiers
moins de 2 de personnes qui sont
difficultés dans l'entreprise peut-être
mais je doute que qu'on ait brusquement
la paix sociale non nous aurons il y
aura toujours des litiges il y aura
toujours un moyen de régler ce litige
le conseil des prud'hommes alors a été
complètement renouvelé
vous avez un conseil toulouse va dire ça
quasiment à 3 381% qu'est ce que ça
signifie pour vous ça vous d'avoir ça
alors ces enjeux les dix ans c'est une
ère nouvelle
il ya une nouvelle législation il ya
deux mains deux nouveaux conseillers
nous allons repartir sur de nouvelles
bases mais notre jeu dit nous parce que
je suis la présidente mais nous
fonctionnons en binôme avec un vice
président qui utilise d'ailleurs l'on se
président voilà qui est d'ailleurs
l'ancien président est notre priorité
sera de créer la cohésion qui existait
déjà avec l'ancienne mandature
comment ça se passe justement comment
créer cette cohésion avec 49 nouveaux
conseillers qui siègent pour la première
fois quand même si c'est quand même pas
voilà ils viennent nous allons redoubler
réunion
que qui fonctionnait déjà nous allons
redoubler le nombre de réunions pour que
les conseillers puissent apprendre à se
connaître et où nous allons
ce qu'ils nous disent que risquent pas
par exemple d'avoir des couacs
parce que c'est la question qu'on peut
se poser quand ils sont tout neufs ils
ne sont pas encore faut peut-être pas
formés est ce qu'ils ne disent pas
d'avoir décroître dans des jugements
il ya quand même la greffière qui est il
a greffé à qui le relient les jugements
notre rôle aussi au président et aux
anciens parce qu'il ya des présidents de
section les notre rôle qui sera de
relire les jugements pour éviter
justement les couacs mais là la décision
toute décision est prise en communauté
je veux dire dans dans la section lors
de l'audience
après l'audience ya un délibéré les
juges discutent de la décision et s'il
devait y avoir un problème
ils ont toujours la possibilité nous
sommes quand même très anciens à être
venus ils ont la possibilité d'en
discuter avec nous d'accord il ya droit
de formation pour ses nouveaux juges
pour le ce nouveau ce est prévu le
gouvernement a prévu deux formés par
l'école nationale de magistrature
ces nouveaux juges
et puis nous aussi nous envisageons avec
l'aide des chefs de cour et de
juridiction de former l'ensemble des
formations sur le code du travail
spécifiquement voilà voilà voilà puisque
il ya deux il ya de nouvelles procédures
le code du travail a complètement changé
nous recommençons tous de zéro même des
anciens ce que nous avons déjà c'est
nous nous avons nous savons d nous
connaissions déjà les procédures qu'est
ce que ça vous a apporté cette
expérience ça fait sept ans que vous
êtes aux prud'hommes qu'est ce que ça
vous a apporté
ça m'a pas ça m'a confirmé dans mon
amour du droit
je suis
sûr que c'est ce que j'aime faire c'est
dans mes sentiments pour pour cette
institution
ça m'a appris à respecter aussi les
autres le préfet justiciables parce que
nous avons plusieurs cas nous nous
rencontrons différents cas il ya de la
douleur de dés des personnes que nous
que nous croisons est la principale
qualité qu'on doit avoir contourné aux
prud'hommes non pas qu'ils écoutent ça
fait partie des deux des qualités que
nous devons avoir une empathie
effectivement puisque quand vous vous
examinez même si vous appliquez endroit
ce que votre jugement
mais vous devez vous vous recevez un
jeune mis des guillemets un public et
vous avez le devoir d'écouter et de
rendre de rendre votre jugement
il y à une augmentation sans rentrer
dans le détail des chiffres me en
augmentation de 5%
10 dossiers traités par an c est comment
vous l'expliquez c'est parce qu'il ya
plus de conflits sociaux
non non non ont par contre nous en ont
pour l'instant on ne se l'expliquent pas
parce que nous avons quand même écoulé
plus de 900 dossiers l'année précédente
d'ailleurs je salue l'ancienne mandature
qui a je vends ton employé le terme
cravacher pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
réouverture de débats pour cette
nouvelle mandature mais nous pour
l'instant nous l'expliquons autres dos
autre objectif que vous aurez pour 2018
c'est encore réduire le temps de
traitement des dossiers en effet de
toutes les façons les lois qui ont été
votées
j'avais les ordonnances qui ont paru
vont dans ce sens sont censés nous aider
à réduire le temps de procédure
il ya des il ya des textes qui est des
fiches techniques qui doivent nous aider
à réduire le temps de procédure merci
huguette bourgeois et si lon journée à
l'écouté de nos programmes merci
[Musique]
c'est ce qu'a dit avec alain livory
n'oublie pas qu'on vous offre des places
pour le concert de made in music ce sera
le 27 janvier à 19h30 au tome goûter à
tout un homme marron cibler vos
invitations vous envoyer musique
m yz ica par sms au 97000 avec un peu de
chance vous serez tirés au sort ce matin
dans matin première pour repartir avec
vos invitations donc pour ce concert
avec made in music
il est 7h30 on retrouve france info pour
un poids sur la cub nationale et
internationale armand perron lauga
carrefour va supprimer 2400 postes en
france d'ici à 2022 ce seront des
départs volontaires qui concerne
essentiellement les sièges du
distributeur et les directions
régionales
le pdg de carrefour annoncé ce matin un
grand virage pour le groupe il veut
réduire ses coûts
développer la livraison à domicile se
tourner aussi vers le bio et le commerce
de proximité ainsi que construire un
partenariat stratégique en chine
par ailleurs carrefour devrait vendre ou
fermer deux cent soixante treize
magasins récemment racheté à dia 2100
emplois sont sur la sellette
carrefour va tenter de reclasser la
moitié de ses salariés et trouver des
repreneurs pour ses magasins
la colère des surveillants de prison les
syndicats rencontrent de nouveau la
ministre de la justice ce sera à partir
de 14h cet après midi le syndicat
ufap/unsa laisse 45 minutes montre en
main à nicole belloubet pour qu'elle
annonce le montant de l'enveloppé
budgétaire sinon il quittera les
négociations les discussions portent sur
des questions sur les questions de
sécurité d'emploi et sur les salaires
une nouvelle campagne pour dénoncer les
violences éducatives allait lancer
aujourd'hui par la fondation pour
l'enfance ces violences peuvent prendre
des formes diverses petites claques
brimades mots blessants
quel parent ne s'est pas laissé aller
sous le coup de la colère ou de la peur
avoir ce genre de comportement
pourtant cela laisse des traces chez
l'enfant jusqu'à l'âge adulte c'est ce
que dit le docteur gilles lazimi
coordinateur de la campagne de fondation
pour l'enfance selon lui l'adulte outre
passe souvent ses droits avec son enfant
est ce que vous le faites avec des
adultes ça vous criez pas vous punissez
pas
vous frappez pas pourquoi d'un point de
vue éthique pensez vous que ça peut être
utile à un enfant qui ne peut pas le
comprendre mais donnez nous donner un
conseil eh ben on peut accompagner
regarder un enfant qui touche une prise
électrique par exemple un petit enfant
au lieu de frapper sur la main ont dû
frapper sur la fesse mettez à cash
prizes est occupé de lui occupez vous de
lui il a besoin que vous soyez présent
il a besoin que vous l'accompagnez et
vous ne pouvez pas avoir les mêmes
exigences avec un enfant de deux ans
cinq ans ou dix ans un enfant qui veut
pas ranger sa chambre à 5 ans ben en
fait qu'on va le ranger avec lui qu'on
va négocier ce qu'on fait avec un
adolescent dans les négociations
faisons-le avec l'enfant en fonction de
son sable de développement le docteur
gilles lazimi attention aux inondations
23 départements sont actuellement en
vigilance orange en normandie région
parisienne dans l'est et le nord-est
ainsi que le lot-et-garonne le rhin
pourrait sortir de son lit aujourd'hui
et la scène déborde hamelin et dans
certains endroits de paris selon les
prévisions la crue du fleuve devrait
atteindre un pic vendredi pic équivalent
à celui de juin 2016 dès demain en
prévention le rer c sera fermé dans la
capitale et au moins jusqu'à vendredi
et puis c'est le grand rendez-vous des
patrons de la planète début aujourd'hui
du forum économique de davos en suisse
sous la neige mais dans un climat
d'optimisme du fait de la reprise
économique
2000 grands patrons et 70 dirigeants
politiques doivent participer à ce forum
dont emmanuel macron angela merkel mais
aussi donald trump qui sera sur place
vendredi ciom armand peyron louga pour
l'info
[Musique]
7h33 sur la première si vous êtes
étudiant vous vivez en colocation sachez
que même dans ce cas précis l'assurance
habitation est obligatoire qui paient
alors et quelles sont les possibilités
qui nous sont offertes pedro montés en
ville y répond bonjour bonjour la
colocation une des trouvailles surtout
chez des étudiants histoire de ne pas
mettre tous ses sous dans un logement en
colocation oui mes respects des règles
également surtout en matière d'assurance
habitation et l'assurance multirisque
habitation est souvent oublié par les
étudiants or elle est obligatoire un
logement non assurée peut-être un motif
d'annulation du bail dans une colocation
étudiante c'est bien connu il ya souvent
des arrivées et les départs de fait le
contrat d'assurance peut être établi
avec un souscripteur principal pour
l'ensemble de l'habitation et sur une
annexe
on mentionne les noms des autres
colocataires la prime d'assurance est
alors envoyé au souscripteur principal
qui se charge alors dans les formes et
ses colistiers pour le paiement
il est aussi possible d'établir un seul
contrat pour l'ensemble des colocataires
touléco souscripteurs doivent inscrire
alors leur nom sur le contrat et donné
leur accord au moindre changement
troisième possibilité si on peut faire
signer un contrat par chambre occupée et
par colocataires il est recommandé de le
faire auprès de la même compagnie pour
le même logement
les parties communes wrestler sur le
contrat du propriétaire de logements
signées habite également si le logement
est loué dans sa totalité
les parties communes doivent être alors
répartie entre tous les colocataires
dans le contrat la colocation le voit
une pratique de plus en plus a répondu
également chez les actifs
cependant avec des règles précises à
respecter
[Musique]
7h35 vous écoutez la première 6h 9h
matin première
et je ne vous ai pas oublié nos amis
turfistes unc écoute depuis ce matin qui
attend les pronostics de daniel weezy je
vous les donne tout de suite il fallait
enfin il faudra peut-être jeu mais c'est
la proposition d' alien il faudra
peut-être joué le 8 le 6 le 15 l'as 11
le 5 le 12 le 13 ans regret le 14 vous
aurez peut-être une chanson en essayant
ces combinaisons l'a86 15 as 11 5 12 13
et en regrets le 14 c'est ce que
conseiller daniel weezy ce matin pour le
prix de marseille qui se court à 8h47 à
l'hippodrome de cagnes-sur-mer et puis
je rappelle les lieux de collecte pour
le don du sang à la maison du don chu la
meynard comme tous les matins à fort de
france entre 9h et 16h mais aussi et du
côté de dit long sur le parking de
l'hypermarché carrefour dillon et là ce
sera entre 9h et 14h si vous habitez le
lamantin il ya des coupures
d'électricité prévues aujourd'hui
jusqu'à 10 heures quartier pelletier
duchesne un quartier petites rivières
font giraumon est à la rue
de la crèche et puis au lourd un coupeur
de aux perturbations sur le réseau d'eau
entre 7h30 et 13h30 dans les secteurs
suivants font grand anse fonds gens
libres acier mort de savon maxime aviv
et et à rivière clair ce sera donc entre
7h30 ça va commencer
jusqu'à 13h30 bon courage à vous et puis
ce matin on souhaite un joyeux
anniversaire à patricia bernard de la
part de carole de ton ami raymond du
robert il se joint aux filles
tout le monde te souhaite une très très
bonne journée un très bon anniversaire
et te disent que la surprise sera de
taillebourg l'espère porto a bâti un
petit dédicace pour patricia b en
arrivant vous tous dont c'est
l'anniversaire aujourd'hui joe dassin
avec et si tu n'existais pas s'ils sont
du jour sur la 1ère
dis moi pourquoi j'existerai
pour traîner dans un monde sans toit
sans espoir et sans regret
[Musique]
et si tu n'existais pas
je serrais d'inventer l'amour comme un
peintre qui voit sous ses doigts mettre
les couleurs
les jours
[Musique]
et si tu n'existais pas dis moi pour qui
j'ai xizt arrêts
des passantes endormi
le jeune
jamais
et si tu n'existais je ne serais qu'un
point
oui
dans ce monde
et qui va je me sentirais pas
j'aurais
joint
de toi
[Musique]
m
il
et si tu n'existais pas témoin comme
angers xi
serai je pourrais faire semblant
mais je
le seul
je crois que
lorette
le secret
[Musique]
pourquoi simplement
[Applaudissements]
regardez
t
et c'est tout
et moi pourquoi j'ai fait
est-ce que ça
pour traîner
deux sans toi sans espoir leur essor
et si tu n'existais pas